service kis und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wie er macht mal was
neues und zwar dachte ich mir wir
schauen uns heute mal ein altes video an
und da sage ich du da bist ok welches
video könnte man sich anschauen und ich
dachte mir dass eventuell das erste face
cam video das ich jemals gemacht hat mir
ganz interessante wahl wäre also dass
wir jetzt genau hier was heute anschauen
das video ist zwei jahre und fünf monate
alt okay leute bevor sie dem
eigentlichen wieder losgeht muss ich
noch kurz aussagen und zwar die runde
die wir uns anschauen dieses alte video
da max und ich ins mega aufgeregt
darüber dass die landsleute tagen auf
dem server deswegen die stimmung bis in
negativer beschweren sie ganz es geht
vor allem ums tagen das müsst ihr wissen
also das thema über das wir die ganzen
reden ist tagen der wir waren immer ein
bisschen sauer aber das sollte als
vorbild sein und wie gesagt das ganze
video dreht sich um das thema tage aber
trotzdem ich frag mich wie ich so etwas
jemals hochladen konnte also es ist
wirklich es ist hart ist das wirklich da
und dachte aber so habe ich das wirklich
hoch gelegt aber es werde jetzt sehen
okay die hamas ja man ja man drei punkte
gebracht und erst mal diese face camp
qualität hat ihr es gesehen die fans
gerade ungefähr so ein frame pro sekunde
dann natürlich auch leute
es wäre zu leicht das licht von vorne
kommen zu lassen so wie es heute machen
für die richtige beleuchtung der fans
gern ein das licht muss von hinten
kommen und zwar von oben hinten um die
maximale qualität der beleuchtung
sicherstellen zu können
ihr wollt darauf hinarbeiten dass sie am
ende so to face seid ja also eine seite
hält eine seite dunkel dass das beste
was wir machen können der fei seht ihr
die produktionsqualität ja ich habe fünf
stunden an diesem video gesetzen fünf
stunden lang aufs geschäft fast fünf
stunden fünf wochen habe ich nur an
diesem video verbracht und irgendwie ist
er doch der facetime rahmen im fucking
intro
herzlich willkommen zur ersten runde
alles klar die qualität zieht sich
einfach weiter der fucking klatscher ist
drauf viele machen das so lese am anfang
hat alle aufnahmen staaten face kern
hohen gameplay wand klatscht man einmal
damit alles synchron ist kann man den
klatschen jeder audiospur aussuchen kann
die übereinander legen sodass die
synchron sind
ich habe es tatsächlich nicht
hinbekommen diesen klatsche
herauszuschneiden
ich habe ich die videos überhaupt
geschnitten damals und natürlich auch
diese geile facebook im rahmen aus
pocking bambus bock drauf ich hoffe euch
gefällt es auch hat mir die kommentare
sehen wollt oder lieber andere spielmodi
genau und es geht los
mag ich so gut beschreiben nicht hast du
den typen gefilmt juni schwere der wird
gebannt
aber okay das gibt mir auch nur die
hacken schwert aber ganz ehrlich wenn
ihr so ne scheiße macht es hat extra
nicht tage erstmal kurzen blick auf die
hauptleute ok wahrscheinlich jeder pvp
und über wird euch sagen dass ihr euer
wichtigstes item öffnen gut erreichbaren
hotkey legen sollte
und für mich ist der hotkey 1 relativ
gut erreichbar komme ich ganz gute in
dierath em-vierte meine finger so für
tastaturen und welches item packe ich
auf fucking hotkey slot 1 in fucking sid
ich brauche ein krasser minecraft ein
blaues wunder also wirklich krass heute
bin ich heute immer noch hallo ja ach
ich bin heute immer noch in minecraft
nur okay ich bin kein stück besser
geworden ok alles klappt leider kein
essen ich hab noch reizen
ohne scheiß okay jetzt haben wir raus
was empfiehlst du gerade empfunden als
du geschrieben hast
da sind ja jetzt gesagt jetzt gesagt was
auch verlaufe die profis chris und die
person sich dann doch getan hat ja jetzt
ein schönes viererteam oder wie ja okay
das ist dann eben eine kleine talkrunde
what the [ __ ] is key teppich laufen über
die map der addierte bin mir der team
mit mir der team mit mir dann haben wir
50.000 team oder kommt zwei gegner und
die boxen sich geil an wird sich freuen
da hinten alter zweierteam gegen für
gegen fünfer team
gesehen weiter
ich habe tatsächlich gemacht haben
gefehlt
ganz ehrlich es ist halt zweifel games
wir sind schon im dm alter ist so viele
leute ist zu viel
was ist dieses video man die leute ich
hab mir da ziemlich gefunden
das ist meine vertretung
dabei hab ja nicht ein sondern zwei hüte
und nicht irgendwelche kopf schoss
bitte lasst es einfach bitte lasst es
und die mittel direkt drei gegner
gottlieb lisicki ist hier alte das
einleben alternativ gutes tut dies gut
die materie gibt mir okay ich hab zu
rücken
ich weiß ich weiß einfach nicht was ich
sagen soll ich fluche am laufenden band
die sind kesselflicker am laufenden band
so schlampig hier zu kriegen wenn sie
sterben oder sein
und am schlimmsten ist dass er den game7
weil die einfach runter haben tagen ist
ein straftatbestand
auf jeden fall dass die todesstrafe
wie kommt man in seinem leben auf die
idee dass die todesstrafe für fucking
tagen in minecraft zweifel games
angemessen welcher geistig gesunde
mensch kommt in seinem leben auf diese
idee wie kann kann sein dass diese
person die diese musik was einfach ich
war vor zwei jahren wie geht die ich war
so ein [ __ ] alter
sorry aber ich musste so direkt sagen
also unfassbar ich glücklich ich komme
gleich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen
soll
weil es einfach so komisch schräg und
keine ahnung falsch auf allen möglichen
ebenen ist werden wir noch hier unsere
komischen vergleich machen sind wir
schon dabei und schalten jetzt in final
fight
ich meine man weiß ja auch nicht wieder
verfällt ausgehen
ja ich wollte wissen ob das projekt
rover sport hat weil man da ja
eigentlich schon gesehen hat wie die
runde ausgeht am ende
und dass ich sie gewinnen okay okay dann
ist es auch nicht lustig wenn ich so tue
als ob ich mit stiften telefonieren
würde
aber okay gut alles darauf welche auf
irgendwelche leute die arbeit ja man
jammern 83 punkte die mir gebracht und
meinen zu ersten games mein erster sieg
okay es war einfach meine erste runde
gewonnen habe es ist hart wenn sie das
wort hierfür ist quatsch das ist so
dieser moment wenn ihr irgendwas
peinliches seht wenn ich also das zieht
sich wirklich zusammen das ist quatsch
und dieses ganze video ist einfach ist
einfach krank und ich muss auch sagen
dass wir hat mich so schockiert dass ich
teilweise ich konnte teilweise einfach
nicht lustig sein
seid mir nicht böse ich konnte dieses
video hat mich teilweise so schockiert
dass quasi ich vor nicht mal drei jahren
so drauf war